hey Colonel Brian here with a special
tip a quarantine tip for you celebrities
now many of you are you're quarantined
your social distancing you're in your
home that's great
but many of you are posting videos okay
which is fine that's terrific
the problem is we don't always look our
best we don't have our hair and makeup
teams the point is this I'm worried
about these areas here some of us are
starting to get up there getting on a
little in years I myself recently turned
40 and one of the issues is that this
area can sag you can get kind of what's
called sloppy throat sloppy throat and
melty jaw and everything starts to just
turn into ice cream down here and I'm
seeing it in some celebrity videos the
neck can get a little sloppy the jawline
can get a little sloppy first you need a
cap put a cap on right there you wonder
why the cap I'll tell you why you're
gonna be using strong industrial tape
you start at the top
[Music]
okay then if you still want a tighter
jawline you can use these bungee cords
there give it any hardware store and
look at that that's a strong jawline
right there look at that jawline and now
I'm ready to talk to my adoring public
hi everybody
Conan O'Brien here and I'm looking good
and feeling even better so take it from
me this is the way to go yes really
mistake let's get dinner
you